[Music]
he never gets the credit though he
doesn't get the credit so i'm gonna give
him credit yeah i don't know
imdb that's the only credit we put on
every video because db
that's the only thing burke wants let's
have a moment to just clap for our dps
[Applause]
unheralded dp of jk news big box
big white con underrated i never
appreciate it
assistant no nobody ever says it okay so
have you guys ever tried to have sex
with a traffic cone yes
back story no yeah we're moving i'm kind
of shaking that i never did what is it
i've stuck my finger in it i have stuck
my finger in the top hole i think i'm
too small
have sex with this guy yeah yeah yeah i
think my dick's too small
yeah i wonder what's inside the hole's
like that big what about the other side
then it gets bigger hey i ain't fit in
that room i mean you know what i do
i pick it up and i'm talking
women have sex with the cone yeah they
could they could if they wanted i'm sure
if you watch
something not all the women
not all the woman he's seen chicks do it
with like
a little tea so yeah whatever you
interesting he has a great
like video list that he could send i
like i like to talk into it and announce
things with the traffic code
i'd be like hello hello hello after he
has sex
truly i'm so ashamed of myself that i
haven't tried to [ __ ] one yet
no you shouldn't that's what i feel like
yeah straight to the store after this
that's right buy some traffic costs so
this is from manchester evening use so
this is their worth not mine but they
say a pervert who made headlines for
trying to have sex with a traffic cone
has found himself back in court
over another vile act not even about the
trafficking
that's ancient history apparently he's a
repetitive offender
what do you try to [ __ ] now it starts
off kind of judgy and then you realize
like oh he did this more than once
you know he's back in jail again for
[ __ ] a traffic home
again in public and he was actually
trying to [ __ ] traffic
he was even successful you know about
this or this is just from what the
headline he said
i don't know yet he's just driving on
the road and he sees a construction site
like oh
she's like fighting his lip gloss
[ __ ] runs his finger around the
bridge
that was like what's up girl he spit
his hand what disappoints me about this
one is they say that he was trying to
have sex with i'm like
what did it do how did it resist
his game was now 100 percent on yeah he
was waiting for consent dude he's
respectable okay
he waited too much because then the cops
showed up yeah that's a blue slime on
him you know what i mean
i wonder which side of the cone he tried
to penetrate it doesn't say can you
believe they don't ask these questions
trust me be more specific if you're
gonna do this big side or the the
the the top the peak side which i hope
that he knows the article in first place
manchester united news they're british
people they're
british they're they're from england
yeah they have a british sense of humor
no this is lauren wise lauren wiseman in
her
court reporter the real news is so
he got arrested yeah before for the
traffic cone incident but now he's back
in court over another
vile act okay and no it was not traffic
home related
related sex relations maybe let's guess
what he tried to have sex with please
all right
okay so he likes traffic cones uh
mailbox i i i would
i would keep it something roadside yeah
roadside
um oh the and lightweight like because
it comes like it is
it's rubbery it's soft i can kind of
imagine that but a bulldozer too rough
yeah two two you know maybe a bucket
maybe okay but the hole's too big okay
maybe a gas can before you guess this is
good by the way but i have to read this
real quick
before we move on into what he maybe is
trying to have sex with now
um drunk and drug addled travis trevor
smith
50 years old caught what drug-addled
so he has he has drug in his system
drugs in the system
he was caught by the staff at the wigan
north
western railway station thrusting his
hips
towards the object which was the traffic
cone
while his trousers and underpants were
pulled down in april 2019
holy [ __ ] he was handed a 26 week jail
sentence
26 that seems fair so he was [ __ ] the
air
with the traffic code towards the object
so yeah
[Laughter]
just a little closer yeah it gets caught
yeah okay now
he was hopping his way
but now guess what he was doing this
time
so he's out of jail this is after the
first incident well this is the second
attempt
second attempt so i'm assuming he's on
drugs sir maybe this time
train station i'm thinking he's coming
back from the pub he's [ __ ] up
yeah andre he's at the
train station he looks at the like a
dead
stop sign ten bird yo
donuts donuts remember the ticket
machine
traffic machine ticket machine is up on
that target
or a phone bill tries to stick his dick
in the ticket machine you're all wrong
he was more alone than that
unfortunately he was spotted jerking off
on a balcony
oh what
what's on a balcony was it his balcony
or just a random mountain
you can't just jerk off in your room uh
close the door
he likes the open air open air okay let
me read this
let me read this with the secret balcony
i have to read this this is i think
that's illegal
if it's in your private property they
shouldn't be you're not wrong
hey you should i'll get you a red hat
soon okay
so i have to read this okay
smith breached his sentence so he gets a
26-week jail sentence right and then
like he gets out
and then he breached that sentence after
he was spotted performing a sex act
on a balcony while oggling a group of
teenagers
oh so that's so [ __ ] gross
it gets better we're with you bro a
horrified
onlooker a teenager said she felt [ __ ]
physically sick and called the police
officers described smith sweating
profusely and quote out of breath
as pornography played from his mobile
phone wow
while he was beating off
so he's looking at the teeters and he's
playing porn on his phone and he's
beating off and he's out of breath
oh man this is uh he's got too much
going
on dude he's got issues he got a sex
problem he got sexual this is this is
the cat we're talking about that's the
kind of guy that gets caught up
damn he's handsome though yeah you're
wrong that's the guy that gets a good
looking guy
yeah right if he's keeping together he'd
probably have a good girlfriend yeah if
he wasn't [ __ ] these traffic cones
and stuff
he could end up with a good friend you
know he's definitely jerking off
at a public public life this is when
when you just are too picky
and you know you want traffic cones and
things that are just unattainable
i think it's too much porn too much porn
too much fun
i blame women
[Laughter]
what did you just say so yeah so not
walking around all the time well no i
mean
believe a woman is too sexy if they
weren't so stingy about sex he wouldn't
have to turn to them
[Laughter]
i think we all agree with him it's a
universal truth he doesn't miss
oh my god he's doing too much
obviously he got the porn he got the
girls out there he's jerking off he's
got the cone he's like
he's got a cool leather jacket too much
it's form-fitting dude he's too much
stimulation
guys he's not doing this in his leather
jacket
he's definitely touching his dick in
that picture what are you doing
no he pulled this he pulled so what he
did was he pulled his arm through the
sleeve he left the sleeve here and then
but it doesn't look like he is yeah and
he got the porn going in the same time
he's just sweating all the time because
he's just jerking off constantly he's
out of breath yeah he's like he wants to
be surrounded by sex
stuff it's like can't you know
how would you solve this problem like
what would you if you're a therapist
like what would you tell this dude
and if you don't your your license have
to find
what is the root i mean what do you
think his root is what do you think he's
like i know what my route is
[Music]
girl doesn't like me huh because i'm
ugly piece of [ __ ] hey man
just jerk off once and then take a nap
yeah
well and then tomorrow i'll do it again
but don't do it
all day long on the balcony not on a
balcony choose your place
if it's a private one that's that's okay
that's the private property but then the
balcony no but you can't i mean
even know if it's a private you can't be
like naked if the other people can see
you
but don't look at them if they can't see
you so so you're gonna see if they can't
see you you could be naked all you want
but you can't be just walking around
you're getting beat up
they can't see you that's what dante
bosco says can you be naked right around
your front yard like it's my front yard
i don't think you do that i think you
can run you can run but
not only up to five miles an hour while
you're jerking off
can you sit in your front yard naked i
don't think no [ __ ] way you can't no
no no no
the door open you can't be naked in the
doorway people get slapped like this
yeah you can't do that either in decent
exposure they can't see you even if
you're in your own home what if you're
in the window can't come on
[Laughter]
but if i'm naked i can't just reach down
touch my genitals
scratch a little bit okay
but what if i have to scratch a lot
i got a mosquito bite that's on you the
beach rules like you can scratch your
dick a little bit again
yeah just one time what if you have a
mosquito bite if you scratch one at one
time you gotta go to see a doctor
yeah you spread in some [ __ ] at the
beach you know like how do you have a
lawyer you only get one scratch
you can go
[Laughter]
oh
to say it that's like a crude way to say
it like
that that was scratching your dick or
masturbating jerking off
exactly like beating your meat yeah beat
your meat i think the daffaj is right
yeah it is if that means flying the
airplane or hit the airplane hit the
airplane
hit the airplane how does that work
like head to airplane don't tell that to
the 911 guys because that
that means something else completely
different okay we don't need that again
uh okay so how where where where real
quick they searched the guy's bedroom
just in case those of you who are like i
think he may be innocent
unfortunately they discovered a bag of
cannabis and they noticed that on his
mobile phone pornography was visibly on
display
wow just cannabis that's it that's it
that's all you need
this guy is just a psychopath this guy's
a [ __ ]
crazy smoking pot and you're jerking off
on the balcony
that's crazy you're walling out
swallowing out i'm leaving
so lock them up
if you're jerking off and there's
teenage girls walking by on a balcony
get the [ __ ] leather jacket and [ __ ]
rolling around what the [ __ ] is popping
you [ __ ] traffic cones and you're
only smoking pot what happens if the
dude does hard drugs he's gonna be
but what if he was there for one of his
jacking off first and then the girls
came later
that's their fault i'm sorry i didn't
think of that that's their fault
they can't just walk on the sidewalk
he's crazy he's actually going to be on
an episode of shark tank where he's
debuting
a traffic cone that is [ __ ] it's a
flashlight on the side of him
wait he's gonna go shark tank he's
always got a shark tank it's a
lubricating it's
not lubricated do you think he's gonna
like get out of the box i'd invest in
that i'm not checking out i think you're
not gonna get this message but
people will be like put on that reality
show come on laurie will go for it
what about barb my girlfriend oh yeah
[Music]
you